on ce matin monsieur stéphane bern
chargé par le président de la république
depuis 2010 est d'une mission sur le
patrimoine en péril c'est un sujet
monsieur que bien sûr vous avez à coeur
et que nous partageons tous ici dans
cette commission une manière plus large
d'ailleurs dans cette institution
sénatoriales c'est donc un plaisir de
vous accueillir et de vous recevoir une
nouvelle fois vous étiez venu plus
anciens d'entre nous s'en souviennent il
ya trois ans pour faire un premier bilan
de la mission qui bénéficie depuis 2018
on le sait les ressources issues du loto
du patrimoine c'est un sujet sur lequel
la commission et les nos prédécesseurs
s'étaient battus depuis pendant de
nombreuses années en est très heureux
que ce loto du patrimoine
fonctionne désormais c'est sur un sujet
plus ciblé que nous vous avons sollicité
ce matin à savoir la sauvegarde du
patrimoine religieux nos deux collègues
and ventalon qui doit être derrière son
écran elle est en déplacement pour le
4-2 dans le cadre d'un groupe d'amitié à
l'étranger meehan je crois est pas se
joindre à nous par visioconférence
empires auzias qui est bien présent nos
deux collègues qu'ils prennent nous
présenterons la semaine prochaine le
rapport qu'il prépare depuis plusieurs
mois nombre d'autres commissions sur le
sujet du patrimoine religieux mais je
crois que piaggio vias interviendra dans
quelques minutes pour nous dire non pas
le contenu du rapport puisqu'il est pas
présentée officiellement mais
l'intervention ne sera pas très loin
j'imagine de ce que sera le contenu qui
sera présenté la semaine prochaine nous
souhaitions est évidemment bénéficier de
votre expérience sur cette question du
patrimoine religieux je crois que c'est
à peu près 40% du patrimoine
français
votre mission poursuit en effet un
double objectif ou un triple objectif
celui d'identifier le patrimoine en
danger celui de contribuer à la
restauration et bien sûr à la valeur et
la gestion de ce patrimoine nous savons
que ce patrimoine religieux comme je le
disais à l'instant on représente une
part importante des dossiers qui nous
sont soumis chaque année
d'où nos questions dans quel état
jugez-vous ce patrimoine
vous paraît-il vraiment menacé en quoi
le loto du patrimoine permis t-il de
contribuer à sa sauvegarde la pérennité
du loto est elle désormais à assurer ou
avez vous des craintes sur ce sujet et
enfin faut-il faire davantage pour
sauver le patrimoine religieux et le cas
échéant comment autant de questions
importantes sur cette question sur ce
sujet et je ne doute pas que mes
collègues interviendront pour compléter
ou abordé d'autres questions à travers
leurs prises de parole dans quelques
instants mais avant de leur céder la
parole je vous sais la parole pour un
propos liminaire et puis après comme
nous avions l'habitude de le faire nous
échangerons 60 de questions réponses
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci à tous d'être présents et de
m'accueillir au sein de cette noble
institution pour pour parler du
patrimoine chaque fois que j'ai eu à
parler devant le sénat de patrimoine
j'ai toujours entonne reçu un accueil
favorable je sais que cette cette maison
est toujours sensible à ce qui se passe
dans nos territoires et particulièrement
la manière dont le patrimoine impacte
directement la vie économique de nos
territoires et parle évidemment du
patrimoine religieux est quelque chose
d'important parce que c'est sans doute
le point là où le bât blesse dans la
question patrimoniale en france le
patrimoine castrale finalement se porte
relativement bien dans le mesure où tout
est faible il ya beaucoup de visiteurs
eh bien on fait en sorte de restaurer
pour accueillir des visiteurs il ya une
finalité le patrimoine industriel est en
très mauvais état en tout cas le
patrimoine naturel du 19e siècle nous
essayons avec la mission berne de le
restaurer dans la mesure du possible
mais 30% des dossiers aux étudiants avec
la fondation du patrimoine et bien
concerne directement le patrimoine
religieux qu'ils soient classés ou non
protégé ou non qu'ils soient en activité
j'allais dire
sacralisé ou désacraliser et c'est assez
important et le hasard du calendrier a
fait que cette semaine j'ai dû me
pencher sur les toutes les demandes qui
émanent est à la fois des drac et des
deux des délégués régionaux de la
fondation du patrimoine pour choisir les
sites qui seraient dans le maillage
territorial qu'on annoncera la fin du
mois d'août pour le loto du patrimoine
c'est-à-dire un site par département
j'ai encore une fois été mes bébés mais
vraiment choqué par le nombre de petites
églises de nos campagnes qui sont dans
un état de déréliction
extrêmement avancé et je crois que la
cia il y a un poids j'essaye de
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer dans notre pays il ya évidemment
il a je n'ai pas à faire de commentaires
je constate comme vous comme tous une
déchristianisation les pays qui fait que
les les églises ne sont plus fréquentes
et quand elles ne sont plus fréquentes
et elles ne sont plus entretenues
d'autre part il ya une autre chose c'est
que dans la ligne budgétaire des
communes qui ont à la charge des églises
la ligne budgétaire d'entretien du
patrimoine et bien cette ligne est
souvent mise à profit d'autres choses
c'est à dire qu on n'entretient plus le
patrimoine et toute personne qui dispose
d'un bien que ce soit un petit
appartement ou quoi que ce soit vous
savez très bien que si je n'entretenais
pas chaque année votre patrimoine ils se
dégradent et le coût final pour
restaurer un patrimoine dégradé et c'est
exponentiel donc la facture est encore
plus lourde donc je vois ça partout
c'est à dire que pourquoi je fais le
lien avec la déchristianisation c'est
que ce n'est plus un enjeu électoral
c'est à dire que dans les petites
communes on ne se fait par élire maire
en disant je vais sauver l'église du
village en revanche je vais construire
un stade je vais vous aider pour le
transport scolaire etc ça c'est je le
remarque dans tous les villages où je me
rends
cc je vois des églises dans un très
mauvais état de conservation
les dracs aide dans la mesure du
possible à hauteur de 30 ou 40 % mais la
somme qui est nécessaire pour les pour
les 20% qui restent à la charge d'eads
et des municipalités et bien souvent les
bus faillite et ne veulent pas je
l'assist à des conseils municipaux ils
refusent de soutenir les travaux de
l'église donc il ya des mères très
courageux qui le font qu'y qu'il impose
d'autres n'ont pas peut-être cet
entregent en tout cas cette même
sensibilité au patrimoine donc je vois
des si vous voulez une vision très
contrastées une chose est sûre c'est que
nous avons énormément d'église de nos
campagnes qui sont dans un très mauvais
état et moi ce qui me choque c'est que
voyez vous on n'a pas réussi encore à
faire comprendre que parfois
l'église de campagne c'est peut-être la
seule chose qui reste dans les villages
de la culture parce que dans certains
villages il n'y a plus que ça c'est à
dire où on peut voir un tableau on peut
voir une oeuvre d'art une sculpture on
peut voir un bâtiment roman au gothique
cc et est donc ces essais de la culture
où c'est pas seulement du culte c'est de
la culture ouverte à tous disponibles à
portée de main c'est de l'art et de la
culture a vraiment de proximité et ça on
a on n'a pas réussi a encore à le faire
passer auprès il se trouve que le hasard
encore une fois du calendrier fait que
ce soit rayé le village préféré des
français donc j'ai j'ai pu arpenter
toute la france pour voir nos villages
je pense à la bouille par exemple où le
faisait au maire mais il faut sauver
votre clocher c'est quand même pas
possible on est quelques quelques
kilomètres ça pour catherine rendent
aussi on est juste à côté de rouen je
suis pas possible d'avoir votre clocher
sushis les coûts il faut le faux le
resterai muet oui mais vous comprenez on
a un problème aussi d'ingénérie
administratives et là je touche du doigt
un autre point c'est que quand vous êtes
un maire d'une petite commune rurale que
vous avez 100 200 300 habitants vous
avez une secrétaire de mairie qui vous
aide pour l'état civil pour les
différentes questions voit ce que les
maires sont très solides
à
courbevoie là pour des demandes de
subventions donc il ya toute cette
charge avait proposé de file en temps
mais ça n'a pas je n'ai pas été entendu
qu'il y ait à la mise mise à disposition
des maires d amo d assistance à la
maîtrise d'ouvragé de telle sorte qu'on
puisse les aider à a présenté les
dossiers parce que faute de dossier mais
les crédits remonte sont pas dépensés
enfin c'est vous connaissez ça mieux que
moi donc il ya là une un cercle vicieux
qu'il faut arrêter de toute urgence
parce que nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
dans le jeu un état d' alerte sur nos
églises de campagne et d'autant que avec
les le regroupement des communes et les
communautés de communes vous avez
parfois des communautés de communes qui
se retrouve avec 7 8 10 église et qui me
disent les présidentes dd com com me
disent on va falloir en sacrifier une ou
deux parce que nous on peut pas tout les
sauver et donc ça c'est un discours que
moi je refuse d'entendre mais que j'ai
entendu dans les plus hautes sphères de
l'état et et et contre lequel je me bats
c'est à dire que je pense qu'un pays qui
n'est pas capable d'entretenir son
patrimoine religieux c'est pas une
question de culte c'est une question de
culture c'est une question de 2,2 de
respect de notre histoire de ce qui a
fait les les racines de notre de notre
pays on le doit et puis c'est aussi un
non sens économique
c'est à dire que je souvent il se trouve
dans mon village les gens viennent et
vont voir l'église la première chose
qu'ils vont voir ils garent devant ils
entrent et ils me disent mais vous avez
vu dans quel état elle est si bas oui
mais voilà il faut le dire au maire on
l'aide je l'aide mais mais c'est pas
simple fruit donc c'est la première
chose la première chose que font les
gens c'est d'aller voir l'église du
village elle est au centre du village
comme on disait autrefois et donc côté
de dans un mauvais état et vous pas
savoir le nombre de on a tellement
attendu que maintenant on est dans un
état de catastrophe
c'est à dire que la mission bien ne
répondent à des clochers qui sont
effondrés là la foudre qui est tombée
dès des pans entiers de murs qui se sont
sont tombés en fait c'est vraiment
l'état de catastrophe et donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est à dire on est on est
sous l'avalanche de projet vous avez
j'imagine vu les gens de la fondation du
patrimoine ils peuvent le dire c'est
vraiment on est très sollicités pour
sauver les petites églises de campagne
alors que nous on essaye avec l'émission
berne d'être équilibré entre le
patrimoine vernaculaire le patrimoine
religieux le patrimoine castrale le
patrimoine du xxème siècle patrimoine
industriel et les maisons des illustres
on était obligé mais c'est énorme de
voir sur 7,8 typologie de patrimoine 30%
de l'ensemble de la mission concerne le
patrimoine religieux c'est la grande
majorité des sujets qui nous viennent
qui remonte des petites communes de
300-400 mêmes habitants parce que le
coût d'une église à restaurer tout
toujours autour d'un million et demi et
quand vous êtes dans une ville c'est
plus simple mais quand vous êtes dans
une commune de 200 ou 300 âmes c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'atteindre donc
il faut d'urgence qu'on se mobilise pour
sauver ce patrimoine religieux et j'en
termine avec un point c'est que ce parce
que mon logis au sein de l'émission
c'est pas seulement les églises c'est
aussi les églises réformée et
luthérienne
on a j'étais content de voir je n'ai pas
pu y aller mais à verdun la synagogue de
berlin a été restauré il ya eu celle de
thann aussi parce que vous savez les
églises les synagogues pardon en alsace
il ya une vitalité du judaïsme en alsace
pendant des années aujourd'hui c'est
moins le cas ça appartient à des
communes ne savent pas quoi en faire
faut les restaurer de même pour
certaines églises réformée protestante
et puis des temples tamouls que nous
avons restauré sur l'île de la réunion
des temples indiens a également de telle
sorte que aucune aucune foi n'a été mise
de côté donc quand je parle de
patrimoine religieux c'est tout le
patrimoine religieux quels que soient
les fois qu'ils sont qui sont pratiqués
dans notre pays
merci pour ce propos liminaire qui
évidemment fait écho à beaucoup de
préoccupations que nous partageons avec
vous sans plus tarder j'ai donné la
parole à pierre housieaux peut-être anne
vantal ont scellé dans son écran
interviendra également vous nous fassiez
un point sur la mission qui sera
présenté la semaine prochaine merci
monsieur le président bonjour monsieur
berne je vais je vais parler aussi au
nom d'anne vantal ont avec laquelle nous
avons travaillé dans dans un consensus
absolu donc je l'utiliserai un pluriel
simple uriel de magistère républicaine
mais c'est pour témoigner de du travail
qu'on a fait tous les deux nous
partageons l'essentiel de votre constat
et nous sommes arrivés au bout de
quelques mois de cette mission à peu
près au même au même bilan avec quelques
nuances sur sur les chiffres la france
c'est cent mille édifices religieux ce
qui est l'un des plus gros patrimoines
culturels européens peut-être après
l'italie c'est quarante mille édifice
qui sont encore utilisés pour pour le
culte ce qu'est ce qui est considérable
et parmi ces 40 milliards à 15 milles
seulement qu'ils sont protégés c'est à
dire que l'essentiel du patrimoine
religieux aujourd'hui n'est pas protégé
ce qui est évidemment un problème majeur
alors vous ai parlé de
déchristianisation
je préfèrerais parler de baisse d'une
certaine pratique religieuse je serai
sap l'union c'est sûr sur le propre au
jeu je pense qu' il peut y avoir
aujourd'hui notamment après le vide des
formes d'expression religieuse qui ne
passe pas nécessairement par le culte
dans un édifice ce qui ne rend pas les
choses plus faciles pour autant
il ya environ d'alors on a énormément de
difficultés à avoir des chiffes
solidifier puisque le ministère de la
culture a abandonné tout travail
d'inventaire dans ce domaine et c'est
quand même un gros problème on pense que
il ya entre 2000 et 3000 édifices
religieux dans lesquelles le culte
extrêmement sporadiques voire inexistant
et la question vous l'avez dit c'est
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire pour
justifier auprès des gens qui payent
leurs impôts le fait que ces édifices
qui sont des biens communaux doivent
être continue doivent continuer à être
entretenu ouvert et là on a été très
surpris de voir que il ya un consensus
général
y compris du clergé que nous avons
rencontrés à plusieurs reprises et tout
le monde pense qu'il faut associer lisez
ces édifices du culte c'est à dire pas
abandonner leur vocation religieuse
contrôles existent mais permettre
d'autres activités pour que la société
est très souvent la société villageoise
la petite communauté villageoise
s'emparent de ce patrimoine en y
développant des activités qui permettent
de justifier auprès de la commune qu'on
puisse continuer à engager des fontes
sur leur race leur restauration il y a
une un bilan qui avait été fait il ya
une vingtaine d'années et il n'était pas
arrivée jusqu'à cette conclusion par
manque de consensus aujourd'hui 20 ans
après on peut vous assurer que tout le
monde est d'accord et que ministre du
culte
affectataire communes veulent travailler
sur la co affectation sur une
affectation partager deux de ses dix
villes de cet édifice et ça nous semble
extrêmement importante le le bilan qu'on
fait mais vous le connaissez comme nous
malheureusement c'est que
c'est plus le domaine de l'état l'état
me serre la culture direction du
patrimoine drac nous a dit sur le
patrimoine non protégé
nous c'est fini mais avec la dureté avec
laquelle je voulais qu ce prix on est
incapable avec nos moyens humains nos
moyens budgétaires
d'apporter de la maîtrise de la maîtrise
d'ouvragé aux collectivités et que
quelques financements donc les solutions
existent mais plus du côté de l'état est
ce qu'on a essayé de faire avec avec ce
rapport c'est de montrer que il peut
exister à une autre échelle dans la
relation entre la commune et le
département des solutions intéressantes
à la fois pour apporter de la maîtrise
d'ouvragé est aussi un peu d'argent ce
qu'il ya quelques ressources budgétaires
qui pourraient être
mobilisés donc la question de fond et
c'est là aussi je vous interpelle un peu
c'est est ce que le moment n'est pas
venu sans se lancer dans une grande loi
de réfléchir aux différents niveaux de
compétences de l'état des collectivités
sur le patrimoine nous avons le
sentiment que le patrimoine de proximité
non protégé doit être sorti de la
compétence de l'état qu'il n'exerce plus
et on doit aujourd'hui donner aux
collectivités essentiellement
départements et communes - la région des
outils pour apporter aux communes se
sont elles deux ont besoin et dont vous
avez témoignés très justement c'est à
dire cette impossibilité de mobiliser de
la maîtrise d'ouvragé pour faire face à
des travaux qui sont complexes et aller
chercher des subventions qui existe qui
existe ce très souvent il ya de l'argent
mais les petites communes ne savent pas
comment aller le chercher j'étais très
heureux de vous entendre parler des
synagogues alsacienne parce que c'est un
problème majeur que nous n'avions pas vu
et que nous avons découvert pendant
cette mission alors les synagogues
alsacienne du fait du concordat sont pas
propriété des communes mais propriété
des édifices publics du culte et dans
dans lorrain notamment dans le sundgau
aujourd'hui les communautés juives non
plus les moyens de les entretenir et
tout ce patrimoine est en train d'être
vendue
transformé de telle façon que il peut y
avoir un risque dans quelque temps que
les édifices liés à la pratique du culte
juif en alsace disparaisse complètement
alors que ça a été le coeur
de la judaïté française et que nous
devons notamment par rapport à tout ce
qui s'est passé au moment de la seconde
annexion un effort de solidarité
nationale pour sauver ce patrimoine et
on le dit avec ma collègue anne vantal
ans avec un peu de solennité là il y a
un dossier national et je suis très
heureux que vous ennuyer parler parce
que c'est quelque chose qui nous a
vraiment perturbé
j'enfile à monsieur le président
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est à
dire que sur la compétence la
répartition des compétences fluzone un
exemple moi je
finalement c'est ce qu'on veut qu'on
voit au quotidien qu'il est plus simple
notre église abbatiale dans le village
est en mauvais état il ya des problèmes
pour pour la restaurer on a trouvé
beaucoup d'argent mais il ya plusieurs
plusieurs tranches de travaux on s'est
dit mais les habitants se sont
désintéressés de 2 des travaux qui
durent depuis une dizaine d'années parce
qu'à l'intérieur une voix il ne voit
rien avancer il ne voit rien tokyo 11 et
10 le dimanche dernier on va nettoyer
l'église ses dires elle fait 64 mètres
de long deuxième édifice religieux le
plus important d'eure-et-loir après la
cathédrale de chars c'est pas rien on
était on a une association qui s'appelle
sauvegarde de l'église abbatiale on est
on est allés tous mais la drac nous a
donné juste des recommandations c'est à
dire vous n'avez pas le droit d'utiliser
tel chiffon patel voilà on nous donne
des indications et puis nous on a nos
bras nous nos mains et on y va donc vous
voyez il ya là une déconnexion totale
entre ce qui se passe dans la réalité du
terrain et puis alors ça c'est la faute
fait de ces grandes régions puisque
notre drac et à orly envoyé à 2h30 de
route donc si vous voulez on se fasse il
nous donnait encore ils font beaucoup
d'efforts parce qu'ils viennent chaque
fois que c'est nécessaire et donc avec
notre bonne volonté on essaie de faire
des choses pour qu'au moins les
visiteurs
voit une église en état de 2,2 de
fonctionnement là vous avez mille fois
raison c'est que le culte et sporadiques
la messe dans cette église abbatiale qui
est spectaculaire quand même karen de
nagy renversé elle fait il ya une messe
toutes les sept semaines huit semaines
et pour une vingtaine de personnes donc
ma critique et pas du tout de la vous
avez euros après on utilise les mots con
con qu'on veut pour dire décrit
situation où baisse du culte il ya
d'autres formes de culte vous avez
raison de le souligner mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que un édifice
religieux dans lequel on entre plus ils
se dégradent parce que plus personne ne
voit
les dégradations et il s'y produisent
les pierres qui tombent c'est la même
chose d'ailleurs pour tous les palais
archiépiscopal
j'ai eu une discussion avec l'archevêque
de strasbourg qui me disait je ne
chauffe plus le palais puisque le saint
père nous autorise plus à l'habiter et
il vit dans un deux pièces cuisine et
donc le palette est ouvert pour les
journées du patrimoine
par chance à rouen le palais
archiépiscopal a été réutilisé pour
l'historial de 2 jeanne d'arc donc au
moins il a en lui a donné une nouvelle
vocation
ce qui est frappant dans ce que vous
dites et qui rejoint la réalité de la
mission c'est que souvent on est alerté
par des
dans l'édifice religieux vous avez aussi
tout ce qui est les couvents les
monastères tout c'est énorme patrimoine
religieux des congrégations religieuses
quinon qui n'ont plus lieu d'être il n'y
a plus il ya plus de moi mais plus de
plus de religieux dans certaines régions
je pense par exemple aux eaux à tréguier
les soeurs de tréguier nous appellent
tous les ans elle dépose un dossier tous
les ans c'est énorme énorme alors on les
a aidés en 2018 c'est vrai que pour les
sites emblématiques de cette année a dit
on va encore révélé les soeurs de
tréguier mais ce qui m'a frappé dans
leurs projets de restauration
c'est le projet de valorisation
c'est à dire de ce 10 mai elles se sont
dit mais et elles ont raison c'est au
fond l'accueil des mois n'a plus de sens
ou d où d où des moniales en revanche
l'accueil des enfants autistes l'accueil
d'un accueil on reste dans la charité on
reste dans la
dans la vocation religieuse initial mais
peut-être on peut l'aide sociale l'aide
aux personnes défavorisées l'aide aux
handicapés
l'edo
intergénérationnel faire en sorte que
les jeunes étudiants puissent vivre avec
des personnes
qui sont en extrême dépendance
donc il ya là des projets à établir nous
on essaye de les aider parce que
voyez-vous dans la mission on n'aide que
quand il ya un vrai projet de
revalorisation
clcv le patrimoine pour le sauver
simplement pour que ce soit joli ça n'a
plus de sens aujourd'hui il faut
retrouver une raison d'être et enfin
voilà il faut donner du sens et enfin la
dernière chose à et raison c'est les
compétences je pense que ça n'a plus il
faudrait que ça soit que les communautés
de communes et je vois que mon
département par exemple l'eure-et-loir
le le présent le département est très
soucieux il a il a comme autrefois
albéric de montgolfier
il a il a donné de l'argent pour qu' on
puisse restaurer toutes les petites
églises de
2,2 du département ça c'est je pense
qu'il faut remettre niveau de
compétences aux départements avec les
communes avec une réserve si vous m'y
autorise et c'est le je pense qu'il
faudrait comme il ya la commission du
vieux paris j'espère qu'elle fonctionne
toujours
parfois j'en doute bon pas bon ça c'est
un autre sujet il faudrait qu'une
commission qui puisse de façon très très
pérenne puisse juger de l'importance
patrimoniale des lieux ce que fait
normalement la direction générale des
patrimoines mais qu'il faut renforcer au
niveau local je pense que par exemple le
président de la région normandie et aux
raisons de nommer un conseiller
patrimoine pour pour sa région parce que
c'est important d'avoir une expertise de
2,2 ce qui est urgent qu'on ne fasse pas
n'importe quoi vous voyez moi j'étais
très contente pas y aller avec des seaux
d'eau reste heureux détruit l'église on
y va avec des chiffons qui sont spéciaux
qui n'abîme pas les statuts qui n'abîme
pas les heures les tête de l'eau
permettre dans les toiles d'araignées
sans abîmer les oeuvres voilà il faut il
faut qu'on puisse avoir dans chaque
région dans chaque département au niveau
départemental puisque c'est ce que vous
dit très justement il faut qu'il dise
experts aussi qui protège le patrimoine
s'il n'ya plus la compétence de la drac
il faut imaginer une autre compétence
pour pour éviter que des erreurs
dramatiques soit commise en tout cas il
ya peut-être un exemple que j'aimerais
dire pour pour qu'on comprenne bien
l'enjeu du patrimoine religieux
j'avais alerté le président de la
république le ministère de la culture
lorsque la catho de lille a voulu
détruire l'église saint joseph pour
construire des bâtiments qui rapportait
sans doute plus qui était d'aider des
deux logements pour les étudiants j'ai
dit vous allez avoir un vrai problème
politique à partir du moment où vous
laisser détruire ce bâtiment tout le
monde a donné son feu vert la catho la
demande et la ville de lille a donné son
feu vert franck riester qui est alors
ministre de la culture a demandé un
moratoire
et puis ensuite il ya une lettre du dg
pattes qui a dit au fond il n'y a aucune
valeur patrimoniale dans cette église du
19e siècle permis de démolir elle a été
démolie mais vous n'imaginez pas le choc
c'est à dire que on est dans un pays où
où les français sont alors il ne
fréquente peut-être pas l'église il mais
ils sont choqués quand vous détruisez
une église c et je les comprends je
trouve que détruire le patrimoine
religieux c'est s'est fait refaire
comment faire outrage à notre mémoire
collective de la même chose et là où je
vous rejoins pour pourquoi j'ai été émue
par le sort d'aider des synagogues de
deux
d'alsace c'est que c'est notre mémoire
collective
de même que les églises réformées aussi
et donc il y a c'est faire outrage à
notre mémoire collective que de laisser
à l'abandon ces églises et de me dire au
volant y en a bien une sur cette qu'on
va pouvoir détruire non donc je pense
qu'il faut trouver des solutions
ensemble par la loi par part peut-être
imaginer des scénarios vous avez raison
il ya plein de gens qui se mobilisent ya
par exemple en plus j'ai on a réuni un
collectif de chefs d'entreprise pour
avec la fondation du patrimoine pour
église en péril
sauver ces petites églises de campagne
et je remercie un certain nombre de mes
scènes et je veux donner qu'un exemple
j'avais le maire de beauce m qui la
baussaine pardon pardon là même le maire
de la baussaine c'est chez vous oui le
maire de la beauce m qui m'a appelé mais
besoin de l'argent puis le loto du
patrimoine et il a trouvé qui met pas
assez on a donné 48 50 milles et puis il
se plaint et moi je suis un jour à la
télévision et je dis je suis désolé
parfois la première année c'était en
2018 j'ai voulu aider 250 monument lieu
de sens qu'on fait par an maintenant
évidemment le gâteau quand ils les plus
grands la part est plus petit évidemment
quand vous le partagez
alors que le loto rapporte bon an mal an
plus de 25 millions d'euros par an et
bien ce qui skie françois pinault m'a
entendu le dire à la télévision il m'a
appelé il m'a dit il manque combien pour
la boue scène et il a payé la somme qui
manquait je le dis parce que y'a des
mécènes ya des générosités il ya des
gens qui sont prêts à aider l'église du
village où la synagogue de l'heure de
leur village on a trouvé l'argent par
exemple on parlait de verdun j'ai initié
le projet de verdun avec la fondation du
patrimoine et la fondation du judaïsme
français a mis la 1000e a dit ben on
suit le projet doit vous voyez vous
arrivez quand vous quand vous initier un
projet sais c'est un peu un jeu de
dominos et dire que tout le monde sait
ça sert de levier en fait et je crois
qu'on peut arriver à sauver monument par
monument
pardon je suis toujours très long dans
mes réponses je vous prie de m'excuser
olivier paccaud sonia de la provôté
sylvie robert et bruno retailleau
et merci
merci stéphane bern pour
votre engagement et votre passion votre
foi votre amour du patrimoine c'est vrai
que la france est un dieu un pays béni
des dieux du patrimoine
pierre appelé les 40000 édifices
religieux ça peut dans certains cas être
considéré comme une charge ça toi à mon
avis est plutôt considéré comme une
chance comme un atout pour
l'attractivité de nos territoires
j'ai eu moi personnellement le plaisir
de mener avec notre collègue joseph qui
n'est pas là de rendre un rapport sur
l'utilisation des crédits dévolus au
patrimoine dans le cadre du plan de
relance et beaucoup de choses très
positives ont été faites le plan
cathédrale par exemple mais là aussi la
ruralité avait été oubliée alors vous
insister dessus vous avez bien insisté
sur le fait qu' une église est bien plus
qu'un lieu de culte c'est un lieu de
culture
c'est un lieu social moi ce week-end
comme la plupart mes collègues j'ai fait
plein manifestation j'en ai fait 10 sur
10 j'en ai trois qui ont eu pour cadre
une église une paroissienne à ravenel a
remis 10 mille soixante mille euros de
don à une association de de réfection de
de la commune a réuni dans le vexin il y
avait une exposition de peinture et à
saint thibault on a posé un coq au
dessus de du clocher alors j'ai une
question très précise qui rejoint un peu
ce qu'a dit pierrot zulia soute à
l'heure sur la notion de co affectation
dans mon département de l'oise la
plupart des églises se porte pas si mal
que ça parce qu'on a la chance d'avoir
un département du conseiller
départemental qui met pas mal d'argent
sur l'entretien son patrimoine parce que
la région commence à m parce que l'état
via la detr ce qu'il ne faisait pas
auparavant commencent à mettre aussi un
petit peu parce qu'il ya des communautés
de communes qui mettent et il ya une
communauté de communes c'est celle des
sablons qui depuis 20 ans a entretenu
tout son patrimoine elle a rénové les 20
église y en a que 20 me c'est déjà
beaucoup les 21 glisse maintenant le
patrimoine castrale donc tout le monde
s'y est mis alors je ne sais pas si le
fait de donner un chef de file à pour la
compétence entretien du patrimoine ce
sera une bonne chose parce que quand
tout le monde s'y met on peut avoir des
résultats remarquables faut simplement
une volonté
en ce qui concerne la coopération je
vais vous donner un exemple dans mon
département j'ai une commune s'appelle
catillon fut mme chan
c'était deux communes qui ont fusionné à
la fin des années 60 qui dit de communes
dit deux églises et ses deux églises
c'était compliqué pour la municipalité
de les entretenir ils ont fait un choix
qui a pu étonner surprendre voire un
tout petit peu choqué au début ils ont
décidé de transformer l'une des églises
c'est le cafi catillon en mairie
salle polyvalente c'est la plus belle
salle polyvalente de l'oise avec des
vitraux merveilleux c'est peut-être la
plus belle église de l'oise alors est-ce
que alors il ya beaucoup de communes
d'une certaine taille qui ont plusieurs
églises et qui ont pu parce qu'elle
avait été désaffectée occulte les
transformer en lieux dédiés à la
pratique notamment culturel lieu
d'exposition mais justement est ce que
cette conversion entre guillemets des
édifices religieux
vous choque est ce que ça vous semble au
contraire une voie pour faciliter un
meilleur entretien
une meilleure transmission de ces
pierres de ses vieilles pierres est ce
que c'est une piste à creuser à votre
avis parce que
beaucoup de gens le souhaiterait enfin
moi je les constate et et quand pierre
tout à l'heure a dit qu'il y avait un
consensus moi je connais des prêtres qui
n'ont pas envie qu'ils aient des
concernant leurs églises par exemple
l'évêque de beauvais et pas trop chaud
quand on lui dit qu'il va y avoir un
concert il veut savoir de quoi il s'agit
puis si c'est pas du gospel il en veut
pas trop voilà donc est-ce qu'il faut
pas creuser là dessus voilà
tout
ce n'est la provôté
oui mais merci beaucoup effectivement
c'est un
grand sujet c'est un sujet du patrimoine
religieux
et nous avions avec michel dagbert à
l'initiative de la délégation
collectivités territoriales produit un
rapport concernant le les maires face à
leurs apparats patrimoine historique et
très rapidement c'est vraiment la
question des édifices religieux qui
arrivait au premier plan avec notamment
un événement qui a été non négligeable
aux deux événements non négligeable dans
cette affaire le fait que le l'état
n'assure plus l'assistance à maîtrise d
ouvrage or ces coisy le noeud du
problème c'est à dire à la fois monté
faire le diagnostic
monter le
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour mettre
en oeuvre une rénovation ou non
parfois massives des bâtiments et puis
le montage financier parce que ça reste
un sujet important et on sait que dans
le patrimoine religieux une très grande
majorité n'est pas classé et donc il ya
un vrai sujet de
du fait que ce patrimoine échappe aux
écrans radar mais pas tout à fait c'est
dire qu'à partir du moment où l'état
décide d'accompagner ou les
collectivités décide d'accompagner et
bien à ce moment là même dont classait
les contraintes arrive en pagaille
et donc je souhaitais
dire que healy a peut-être un sujet sur
le classement et trouver une façon de
pouvoir accompagner en être en étant
mois moins ambitieux sur le montant des
factures
et les le programme qui est proposé
parce que les mères moi j'ai encore un
exemple tout récent un amer qui avait
bouclé son budget
l'état propose d'accompagner dans le
cadre du projet du plan de relance
église bon classé la bf intervient on
demande un architecte du patrimoine est
en demande des entreprises spécialisées
la facture est multiplié par vingt et ça
a toujours pas commencé alors qu'il ya
un monde le chantier aurait pu commencer
et il ya je pense qu'il ya une forme
d'urgence qui nécessite une forme
d'urgence administrative
qui permettrait de d'investir
massivement le deuxième événement
éléments ce sont les communes nouvelles
où il avait justement
signalé et
de la part de l'accompagnement de l'état
il est
nécessaire de d'accompagner plus c'est
comme une nouvelle qui a dix communes
rurales 8000 habitants on se retrouve
avec cet édifice religieux à gérer je
pense qu'on pense à la même
commune nouvelle et donc on voit bien
que la cette incommensurable on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas y parvenir le
deuxième sujet c'est le sujet de
l'entretien j'allais dire les questions
la question des églises en france c'est
la question de l'entretien du patrimoine
enfin c'est à dire qu'on retrouve au
sujet des églises toutes les
problématiques contrat au niveau du
patrimoine et donc là tous les ans au
moment du projet passionnant son on
intervient sur la question du budget
entretien du patrimoine et cette veille
nécessaires avant qu'on arrive à des
arrêtés péril et
clairement il serait bien qu'ils aient
un budget entretien au niveau des drac
et qui mériterait d'être estimé destiné
à ce patrimoine religieux parce que
on voit bien que quand il faut entre
protéger un clocher ou le refaire
intégralement il ya il ya une facture
qui est complètement
différente et puis le dernier sujet
c'est dire aussi que les églises sont
des musées dans les églises il y à des
tableaux fashion
inauguré les travaux d'une église ce
week end et des tableaux de peintres
flamands extraordinaire ajoutant il ya
des ja les tableaux il
le mobilier les objets tous les objets
d'office et de culte les statuts et ses
tares et c est tout ce pas traîner
registre s'il ya des registres qui date
du moyen âge ont certaines petites
églises on le sait même pas et je pense
que au delà de l'inventaire du bâti à
cet inventaire de tout ce mobilier qu'il
faut faire et qu'il est nécessaire de
faire parce que ça appartient aussi à
nos trésors nationaux et certains sont
complètement méconnu et eni protéger
donc
peut-être avoir finalement un référent
haddock par département pour pouvoir
faire ce travail
de collations d2
et d'évaluation de tout le patrimoine
complet lié liés aux religieux merci
syli robert vous êtes nombreux à vouloir
intervenir donc si vous pouvez être
synthétique dans les interventions
merci monsieur le président en général
je suis donc je vais essayer de l'être
de nouveau merci monsieur berne en tout
cas et d'avoir cité jurés milloise est
le maire de la baussaine il vous en est
éternellement reconnaissant parce que
c'est vrai que ça a déclenché
l'attention de françois pinault qui est
d'ailleurs très attentif à ce qui se
passe dans mon département et il a fait
beaucoup de jaloux auprès de pas mal de
mer je peux vous dire en tout cas
c'était une belle une belle aventure à
moi je voudrais attirer l'attention mais
du coup ça prolonge un peu les propos de
de sonia sur le patrimoine mobilier et
sur le fait qu' il faut avoir l'esprit
le sort de beaucoup de collections de
livres et archives des communautés
religieuses et des diocèses qui
d'ailleurs sont devenues propriété de
l'état mais qui sont restés dans les
diocèses et qui sont en grand danger
parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
personnel et il n'y a pas de moyens pour
pouvoir les gérer les entretenir et je
le dis d'autant plus que c'est un
patrimoine qui peut disparaître c'est
notre patrimoine national et j'ai
observé et c'est une préoccupation que
je partage avec vous des ventes
publiques de bibliothèques entières de
séminaires de ce dossier zain diocésain
qui sont déjà qui sont en plus pardon de
le dire à la limite de la légalité
et je crois que il faut être vraiment
attentif alors demander à pierre si la
mission intégrée cette question du
patrimoine mobilier mais en tout cas sur
la question de ses archives et des
collections de livres qui peuvent être
absolument magnifique je pense qu'il ya
un vrai danger aujourd'hui l'état ne
s'en occupe pas et il n'y a pas vraiment
les personnels et moyens aujourd'hui
dans les diocèses me sens d'occuper
voilà monsieur le président je crois
avoir été synthétique mais j'alertais en
tout cas sur une dimension qui me semble
aujourd'hui extrêmement important si
nous aimerions tous avoir françois
pinault dans notre département
bruno retailleau
3 3 éléments d'abord pour remercier ses
fans berthe
d'utiliser sa notoriété publique pour
une cause d'intérêt général il ya
tellement entre guillemets de people qui
sont tournés vers eux mêmes et je pense
qu'il faut que l'on salue cette activité
qui est une activité qui est une mission
de service public vraiment à un immense
merci stéphane bern le deuxième élément
le patrimoine religieux bien sûr il ya
l'aspect culturel qui nous relie à
travers l'histoire aux générations qui
fait que en réalité il ya une question
de transmission on parle de la nature un
patrimoine naturel à transmettre mais ça
c'est absolument fondamental il ya
l'aspect économique bien sûr puisque le
les visites touristiques sont aussi en
france des visites du patrimoine
profanes ou religieux et je dirais que
pour nos communes pour nos villages on
n'en parle jamais il ya un aspect
d'urbanisme on est souvent nous élus
locaux fin anciens locaux ou même
sénateur attaché à l'urbanisme mais vous
enlevez l'église au milieu du village et
le village est déstructurée et ce n'est
certainement pas les pavillons
aujourd'hui qui sont d'anciens champs à
vache transformer en tablette de
chocolat qui vont améliorer le cas dans
la qualité dit qu'on offre à nos
compatriotes que ça c'est ses premiers
points que je voulais je voulais
resituer quelque chose de plus large
d'une perspective plus large sur
l'utilité du patrimoine de deuxième
élément ce que je veux dire aussi c'est
comment fait-on maintenant pour pour
avancer la question me semble-t-il de
concerne que marginalement le patrimoine
protégé dans ma région j'ai été prise en
département j'ai pris en
intercommunalités départements et de
régions on a avec l'état
une grille qui nous permet d'avoir à peu
près 80% et parfois même au delà pour
des communes qui sont fille sont pauvres
sur le passage protégé la question c'est
patrimoine non protégé et dans le
patrimoine religieux je dirais même que
ce sont d'abord les églises du 19e
siècle qui ont été construits un peu à
la va vite sur des architectures parfois
pas toujours au top c'est celle là qui
sont qui présente souvent le plus urgent
donc moi je pense que il ya plusieurs il
ya plusieurs éléments que je porter à
votre connaissance sur la question des
compétences moi je suis vous souvenez
dans le cas de la loi note on nous a
vendu à l'époque cette idée que il
fallait plus de financements croisés
parce qu'un jardin à la française c'est
toujours mieux c'est cartésien que c'est
pas ça c'est de la bêtise il faut
préserver la capacité d'avoir plusieurs
financements la communauté de communes
le département et la région et à tous
bien sûr la fondation le loto de settat
c'est comme ça qu'on pourra y arriver et
il faut surtout pas que les
collectivités
plafonne trop enfin moi ce que j'avais
fait pour mon département et la région
c'est que je dis aux collectivités match
personne par exemple à 20% ou 30% cinq
cent mille euros mais vous me faites des
tranches comme ça sur trois ans vous
d'être la faune et et on va jusqu'à amis
en 53 cents donc attention compétentes
de les compétences notamment en matière
départementale je rappelle que la
première tranche fait la une des grandes
compétences culturelles transféré par
les lois de décentralisation
ça a été le département notamment pour
les archives des appartements pas je
pense que pour tout ce qu'il n'y ait
parce que le roux on parle de
regroupements de paroisses aujourd'hui
la re membres non mais parfois c'est
évidemment il ya bien moins de moison
manucurés mais il ya aussi les communes
nouvelles très bien mais dans le
regroupement des paroisses il va y avoir
les archives qui pourraient disparaître
je pense que c'est le rôle alors très
clairement des archives départementales
autant je ne veux pas d'un chef de file
à sur le patrimoine religieux autant sur
cette question là je pense que c'est
clairement le département et on a un
corps notamment qui vient de l'école des
chars etc qui est l'un des meilleurs
corps au monde il faut s'appuyer sur
deuxième chose sur les objets
d'antiquité etc voilà c'est aussi
notamment le département parce que là
corps on peut s'appuyer sur des
conservateurs c'est ce que j'ai fait
qu'ils peuvent mettre en lumière un
certain nombre de collections de
chasubles sphinx yattara d'objets de
beaux objets cultuels ça c'est et
dernière chose sur les compétences moi
je pense que évidemment je pense que on
pas souvent ici de décentralisation je
pense que la déconcentration se
doit-elle de redonner aux préfets de
département le rôle de coordination de
toutes les administrations d'état et je
pense qu' il faudrait soumettre les
dracs aussi enfin à une forme là aussi
d'actions d'autorité du préfet
département passe le préfet département
il a cette finesse d'un avis que n'a pas
le préfet de région et les grosses les
gros administrations départementales
drague le dre rex et terre afin que vous
connaissez comme moi sont en suspension
ce sont des fausses déconcentration
elles sont classées directement sur
leurs administrations centrales et donc
ça ne fait pas avancer le schmilblic
troisième élément dernier il faut
trouver
des utilités nouvelle bien sûr cultuelle
évidemment quand le culte est toujours
célébrée quand il ya une affectation au
sens de la loi de 1905 mais il faut
vraiment avoir aussi penser à autre
chose ce que quelques exemples un
exemple nous on a mis en valeur derrière
des vitres blindées
les trésors des petites églises le
département la région subventionner ce
qui permet d'avoir que ce soit sur du
tissu chasuble sur l'idée qu' alice et
cetera tu sont les éléments précieux
dans les petites églises ça permet
d'avoir une visite on peut aussi un des
moyens très simples aujourd'hui avoir un
déclenchement d'une musique et aussi
d'un commentaire qui permettent une
lecture expliquée pour ça ce sont des
choses qui permettent de rendre le
patrimoine plus plus accessible
deuxième chose je pense moi on a sauvé
une église du 19e on ya fait un centre
du vitrail les danses on se retourne
très facile c'est le dossier qui pivote
dans un sens manqua le culte dans
l'autre sens quand c'est pour le
l'exposition temporaire on l'exposition
permanente mais il peut y avoir
évidemment qu'on va pas est transformée
en boîte de nuit quand elles sont
toujours affectés au culte mais il peut
y avoir dans les connu un objet culturel
des deux salles d'exposition ceux qui
peuvent permettre justement à ce nouveau
patrimoine de retrouver une raison
d'être ce que je voulais dire très
rapidement n'oubliez pas quand même j'ai
bonheur de présider la girolle une fente
euros
le patrimoine a une puissance de
suggestion et les créations et les
résidences d'artistes
c'est très souvent dans ces lieux là
parce que ce sont des lieux inspirants
donc n'opposons pas le patrimoine qui
seraient fermés sur le passé et la
création qui serait ouverte sur le
présent et l'avenir les choses parce que
je vous le dis rapidement alors
catherine morin desailly monique de
marco et alexandra bord chaudfontaine
merci présidence à lui la présence de
ses fans d'un c'est toujours un plaisir
de vous entendre un cher stéphane
pour rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
bruno retailleau beaucoup de
collectivités tiennent salon maintenant
des politiques en faveur de la culture
en général du patrimoine et la création
particulier qui articule justement la
mise en valeur des lieux de patrimoine
et avec un amusant résidences d'artistes
des ex projet d'exposition tout cas
c'est ce qui se fait dans pas mal de
deux régions maintenant je note mais
c'est ce qui est bien sûr à à encourager
pour rebondir également sur ce qui a été
évoqué sur la répartition des
compétences je ne sais pas si
définitivement il faut attribuer les
compétences à tel ou tel niveau de
collectivités territoriales serait un
petit peu plus prudente comme l'a
rappelé bruno retailleau l'esprit la loi
d'autres roulent et différents niveaux
de collectivités territoriales ont
réclamé à tout prix de conserver la
compétence sur la la culture maintenant
c'est vrai que elle peut être fléché ce
qui se passe assez naturellement
j'observe que dans pas mal de régions en
réalité sont les communes et les
départements qui interviennent sur les
églises notamment non protégés et que
les régions vont elles aussi intervenir
sur le patrimoine religieux mais
davantage sur les très grands édifices
qui nécessite la mobilisation de fonds
extrêmement important les grandes
abbayes cathédrale les grandes églises
qui sont pas forcément d'être chaud
propriété de de l'état et que ça se fait
un peu un peu naturellement au gré des
choses au demeurant je pense que les
communautés de communes sont appelées
davantage à participer parce qu' une
petite commune très clairement elle ne
peut pas trouver les moyens d'aller
restaurer sont son église et qu'à
travers un projet à l'échelle de la
communauté de communes qui donne aussi
une affectation et un usage partagé
comme ça a été évoqué il ya des tas
d'exemples sur le modèle québécois aussi
qui est intéressante à la regarder elle
ça permet de construire un projet à
l'échelle d'un bassin de vie et ses
projets ils peuvent aussi être financés
par les départements et les régions en
cadre des contrats de territoire autre
cadre des contrats de développement
culturel de territoire dont je pense
qu'il faut que chacun s'y mette en
réalité dans le cadre peut-être de
comités régionaux du patrimoine aussi
qui pourrait se créer pour traiter cette
question de l'urgence du patrimoine
religieux
ça me semble tout à fait utile de se
mobiliser aussi sur la question des
édifices en péril en absolu péril des
églises fermées je crois que
l'observatoire du patrimoine religieux
noter que 500 édifice était ferme et
fermé et d'autres sont très grand danger
très très grand danger donc comment
d'abord on accompagne les élus dans la
prévention de ces dangers vu la
situation sanitaire entre 1,18 et
surtout qu'est ce que l'on fait pour
créer peut-être un fonds d'urgence dans
lequel chacun participe mais ça c'est un
vrai sujet parce qu'on n'a pas le cas l
incendie de notre dame encore l'écho
soit pas encore complètement établi mais
il ya d'autres édifices religieux qui
ont brûlé et ce en passe de pouvoir
brûler un jour ou l'autre donc comment
on prévient ce péril moi c'est ma plus
grande préoccupation aujourd'hui est
lusage partager doit être absolument
promu et on doit être inventif créatif
et je crois que ça redonne complètement
le sens
rien faire un bien un lieu de
socialisation et à cet égard dernier
dernier remarque je pense qu'il faudrait
absolument que l'europe participe à
travers ses fonds de cohésion les fonds
de cohésion leader fait dans le mot
cohésion on peut se dire que le
patrimoine participe de lacs et de la
delà de la cohésion et il faut une porte
d'entrée clairement établie désormais de
l'europe d'affirmation de ses
compétences rien n'empêche aujourd'hui
dans les traités européens et que l'on
puisse utiliser aussi ces fonds pour
pouvoir dans le cas d'un projet de
territoire qui participe du
développement économique de la qualité
de vie de l'environnement agir monique
de marco
je vous remercie
je suis donc sénatrice de la gironde un
très beau nez partout mois aux riches en
patrimoine bien sûr je voulais rebondir
justement ce que voulait dire peuvent
aller chercher les enfants et les fonds
européens se pense que c'est possible on
n'y pense pas suffisamment c'était une
de mes suggestions mais je reviens sur
une piste qui n'a pas été encore abordé
nous avons vu que suite à un incendie
notre dame donc il ya eu une forte
mobilisation de mécènes elle me regarda
mais aussi donc de simples citoyens qui
ont contribué financièrement à
participer à la rénovation
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faudrait aussi
motivés et intéressés ce petit
patrimoine local
donc un mécénat un mécénat peut-être
industriel particulier citoyens et
comment pourrait-on faire ceci et à
quelle échelle
très synthétique
[Musique]
alexandra burke se font ça qui est
derrière son écran alexandra
[Musique]
de payement le micro avec sera autant
pas oui vous m'entendez
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues je vous dis maman on va
remercier monsieur berne temps pour
votre présence que vos propos et
explication et salue le travail bien sûr
de mes collègues alban talons et pierre
ouzoulias alors dans une tribune de
juillet 2020 vous êtes revenu sur l'
incendie de la cathédrale notre-dame de
paris vous avez souligné d'ailleurs avec
justesse que ce drame avait tant marqué
les esprits croyants et non croyants du
fait que chacun français notre dame
éternel invulnérable pourtant la réalité
est tout autre et là encore vous le
constater en estimant à 5000 le nombre
d'églises en souffrance à travers la
france alors bien que leur entretien
incombe et bien au maire tous ne
parviennent pas bien sûr à remplir cette
mission et se retrouve souvent
impuissant face au délabrement de leur
patrimoine religieux on en a parlé tous
par ailleurs ne peuvent pas forcément
compter bien sûr sur le soutien d'un
conseil départemental comme c'est le cas
dans mon département des alpes-maritimes
où je siège et où nous avons pu soutenir
assez récemment deux chapelles notamment
à thiais bâton ou encore à nice alors
pour faire face à une partie notre
héritage qui part en poussière il est
impératif que nous réagissions et
d'oignons bien au maire qu'aux citoyens
des leviers d'action efficace le loto du
patrimoine bien sûr en étant en 2017 aux
alliés suggéré de rendre payantes
l'entrée des cathédrales pour les
touristes comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs
dans de nombreux édifices religieux dans
le monde donc ma question est la
suivante maintenez vous votre
proposition et si oui comment parvenir à
distinguer donc à faire payer le
touriste du croyant qui vient se
recueillir
et enfin dernier interventions ces deux
solides rex l'air qui est également
rapporteur des crédits budgétaires pour
notre émission sur le patrimoine oui
bonjour bonjour monsieur berne chers
collègues alors je suis en argentine aux
missions d'information mais je tenais
vraiment être présente à cette audition
ce matin en qualité de rapporteur pour
le patrimoine mais surtout pour avoir
l'occasion de vous dire monsieur berne à
4h30 au cas où tout le respect et l
estime qu'ils sont les miens pour votre
engagement pour le patrimoine non
protégé à la collectivité européenne
d'alsace où je suis élue je suis
déléguée au patrimoine bâti et la
mission qui est la mienne est de tout
faire pour sauver ce qui nous reste de
nos maisons en scène
alors sachez monsieur berne que vous
lire vous écouter vous regardez faire
aussi me donne eu le courage de porter
cette mission je sais que la sauvegarde
des maisons anciennes vous tient très à
coeur et que vous soutenez fortement
l'engagement associatif qui est très
fort dans ma région je voulais vous dire
que nous savoir à leurs côtés donne à
tous ceux qui se mobilisent qui donnait
tout pour leur patrimoine les meilleures
raisons du monde les meilleurs argument
et l'énergie aussi qu'il faut pour
continuer leur combat parce que c'est
bien souvent de cela qu'il s'agit
alors je suis élu d'une commune de 900
habitants à qui on vient de présenter un
devis de 700000 euros pour rénover son
équipe simplement pour effectuer les
travaux minimum qui permettrait d'éviter
qu'elle ne continue à se dégrader je
suis également président d'une société
d'histoire qui depuis 15 ans se
mobilisent pour préserver pour restaurer
pour valoriser et enfin pour transmettre
les traces de l'histoire juive qui a uni
en son temps les communautés juives et
chrétiennes du sorgho et grâce à une
trentaine de bénévoles nous collectons
des fonds qui ont permis déjà de faire
ce travail de restaurer tout un quartier
d'ailleurs je vous invite à venir nous
voir à six mouvements aussi et ensuite
nous ferons la même chose pour notre
église à dix minutes de chez moi la
commune dira zone 1500 habitants elle a
acheté il ya une quinzaine d'années la
belle synagogue du village qui était
devenu un squat pour tenter de protéger
ce lieu qui racontent qu'ils témoignent
aussi l histoire de nos petites
communautés j'ai eu malheureusement
aucun projet donc aucun financement nous
permet d'envisager sa restauration et
comme notre église à durmenach dans mon
village se dégradent chaque année
davantage et un jour il faudra la
détruire pour des raisons de sécurité
alors les finances des communes sont
aujourd'hui ce casse on l'a dit tout à
l'heure on le sait tous pour garder pour
faire venir des femmes il faut
construire de nouvelles écoles des
équipements culturels et sportifs
c'est très bien on est tous d'accord là
dessus mais comment dans ce contexte
nous parlementaires pourrions nous
soutenir les élus qui font le choix
courageux de
prioriser de reconvertir d'intégrer leur
patrimoine cultuel dans les projets de
la mandature tout en s'assurant de
l'adhésion des habitants de leur
territoire merci musculaire
ils s'abîment fait partie des rares
personnes qui font lever les sénateurs à
4 heures du matin j'ai très touchée mais
qu'elle avait correspondu avec avec
madame text l'est je vais essayer de
répondre si vous me l'autorisé tous ces
points je pense j'ai écouté toutes vos
interventions et ça m'a beaucoup touché
et je pense à un point majeur qu'il faut
absolument qu'on martèle auprès de
l'opinion publique et des et des élus
dans notre pays il ne faut surtout pas
opposer les pierres aux hommes parce que
et
il est trop facile de dire avez vous
défendez les vieilles pierres mais vous
défendez pas il ya tellement de drames
en ce moment la pauvreté le lait etc non
les les les les pierres
révèle les hommes et les hommes réveille
les pierres ça c'est la devise d'actavis
talent que je reprends mon compte mais
pour paraphraser lamartine on n'a pas un
coeur pour les hommes un coeur pour les
pierres on a du coeur où on en a pas et
je crois que quand on a envie de sauver
derrière les pierres il y a des
aventures humaines chaque pierre de
notre pays et est bien raconte une
histoire quand les langues se taisent
parce qu'on apprend pluie les pierres
parlent encore et donc c'est ça que je
veux sauver c'est à dire que c'est il
faut que l'on comprenne que ce
patrimoine religieux c'est notre
histoire qu'on soit croyant ou qu'on ne
le soit pas
c'est notre histoire et on n'a pas le
droit de l'abandonner parce que derrière
il ya des hommes et des femmes qui les
ont bâties et qu'aujourd'hui encore il y
a quarante cinq mille emplois qui sont
directement liés à ces métiers d'art qui
sont des savoir faire d'excellence à la
française qu'on est en train de perdre
pour certains alors évidemment il ya le
chantier de notre dame et notre dame
c'est un peu la fpt l'arbre qui cache la
forêt
c'est à dire je ne fais pas de jeu de
mots avec la forêt de notre dame qui est
malheureusement un flambé mais c'est au
nom on devrait saisir et on n'a pas
encore fait saisir la chance ce chantier
de notre dame pour valoriser les métiers
d'art pour faire en sorte que est bien
partout il y aider des jeunes qui ont
envie d'apprendre c'est métier de
couvreur de jeu de de tailleur de pierre
de charpentier de vitrailliste même s'il
faut se battre à l'europe pour
évidemment qu'on olympienne le plan pour
les pour les pour les vitraux bon ça
c'est un autre combat qu'il faudra mener
dans les semaines qui viennent mais vous
voyez c'est ce sont des chantiers du
patrimoine qui qui donne de la colonne
vertébrale je prends toujours là ggg
aider une association qui s'appelle acta
vista ce sont des jeunes qui sont en
dessous des moins jeunes d'ailleurs
qu'ils sont en en déconnexion de la vie
qui sont en grand danger de basculer
dans
parfois dans un mauvais côté eh bien on
leur redonne une colonne vertébrale
grâce au patrimoine il se réveille le
matin et ils vont travailler sur les
chantiers du patrimoine et ils partent
avec un diplôme amitié et on les a
sauvés donc ça c'est le premier point
n'opposons pas les pierres et les êtres
humains maintenant je vais répondre à
toutes vos questions
je réponds peut-être même d'experts
parce que parce qu'elle est loin et
qu'elles aient calé et ghetto je pense
que là où il ya un moyen des décès coeur
de bourg on a fait coeur de ville mais
l'action coeur de bourg devrait
permettre de recréer du lien social dans
les bourgs de nos de nos villages et
c'est vrai que remettons l'église au
coeur du village l élan elle est comme
monsieur retailleau le disait très
justement c'est pas seulement un lieu de
culte c'est un lieu de culture et même
la prévôté le disait aussi vous l'avez
raison de le lire c'est de l'art c'est
de l'histoire c'est de la culture c'est
du mobilier cdd statut cdd des tableaux
c'est aussi des registres c'est tout
cela qu'il faut préserver parce que
c'est notre histoire il n'y a pas de
raison de sauver uniquement les grands
monuments
ccc c'est ça qui est injuste que j'ai
trouvé injuste dans notre dame de paris
si vous voulez c'est qu'on trouve 900
millions pour sauver notre dame parce
qu'on est tous bouleversés mais qu'à
aucun moment au 10 au caissier un peu
s'il ya trop d'argent eh bien on va le
saupoudrer pour sauver les petites
églises de nos campagnes moi ce qui me
touche le plus c'est la ruralité c'est
que c'est ces mères dans ces communes
qui se démène pour sauver leur église
ils n'ont aucune rice direct sur la
médiatisation
personne ne s'intéresse à eux on les
méprise vous savez des vous franchissez
la grande couronne vous voilez déjà
moitié moins de dotations au public a
déjà comme j'ai dit un ministre j'ai
perdu la moitié de mon cerveau à partir
du moment où j'arrive en eure-et-loir et
qu'on m'explique pourquoi je vaux -
quand je vis à la campagne dans mon
village
c'était une forme d'injustice
celle de ne pas être légales déjà on n'a
pas de 3g on a même on et nt1 on n'a
même pas de téléphone pour qu'on n'a
rien on n'a pas de service public on n'a
pas de médecin et en plus on nous
détruit notre église où on la laisse
tomber en ruine gypa l'église ou au sens
religieux du terme mais au sens culturel
et ça c'est quelque chose au-delà alors
qu y eut cette polémique quand j'avais
parlé je réponds en même temps la
question de l'entrée des cathédrales
j'avais juste émis cette idée que
regarder quand vous allez place saint
marc à milan à pardon à à venise mais à
milan à la cathédrale au duomo à firenze
ou à milano vous avez vous avez une file
pour eux pour aller prier et puis vous
avez une file pour visiter et vous ne
dérangeait personne et vous payer un
droit d'entrée pour visiter mais
évidemment j'ai eu des discussions avec
tous les avec monseigneur vingt-trois
c'était un peu compliqué avec
monseigneur ravel c'était plus simple
avec avec d'autres c'était ça s'est
révélé plus simple aussi c'est que healy
a depuis
1905 il y à une rancune tenace du clergé
affectataire contre l'état vous nous
avez pris nos édifices religieux eh bien
vous payez alors moi j'ai juste mis à
plat cette chose dans très bien voulait
pas qu'on paye pour rentrer dans les
églises mais dans ce cas là pourquoi
vous fait de payer pour l'entrée du
trésor pourquoi vous faites payer pour
l'entrée de la crypte pourquoi vous
faites payer pour pour les boutiques
pourquoi vous fait de payer pour aller
visiter des tours de notre-dame c'est
une vraie question aussi puisque ça
appartient à l'état vous n'avez pas fait
de l'argent sur le dos de l'état quand
même ou alors vous donner une idée une
licence il ya une une convention qui
signait alors là il était gêné g j'ai
senti j'ai demandé à l'état au cabinet
du président la république qu'on fasse
pas qu'on fasse une étude sur justement
toutes les dérogations et à l'airé
terral de strasbourg vous le savez très
bien on ferme à 11h45 on fait payer le
ticket d'entrée pour aller voir
l'horloge astronomique et puis dogon
paye puis hop on rouvre gratuit 12h15
mais ccc des facilités qui sont donnés
mais dans ce cas-là ouvrons la
discussion alors tout cela vient du fait
que l'état doit garantir le culte
gratuit dans l'est donc j'ai plus
toucher à cette question de faire payer
les l'entraidé cathérale parce que j'ai
vu que c'était un sujet épineux et que
ça dit c'est ce qui fait la différence
entre un pays laïque où on a on a on
april et les lélés les biens du clergé
avec d'autres pays par exemple
l'allemagne ou l'autriche l'allemagne et
un est un exemple toutes les églises
toutes les tous les édifices religieux
sont superbement bien entretenues tous
pourquoi pas ce que vous payez l'impôt
sur le culte est un impôt du culte et
donc si vous voulez vous faire enterrer
selon les rites catholique juif
protestant et bien il faut payer toute
votre vie et donc avec cet impôt
comprenez nous on veut pas payer et puis
après on va sur intel mais bon ça c'est
une autre question ça c'est genre de
bruit en allemagne ots - le patrimoine
religieux est très bien entretenu alors
maintenant la conversion monsieur pas
que vous répondre à vos prisons la
convention église concert ya est
évidemment le clergé affectataire la
plume en lui tend le bras en permanence
quand on veut organiser des concerts
dans les églises et donc ils demandent
évidemment à ce que ça soit plutôt
plutôt spirituel plutôt religieux ce que
je peux entendre aussi pour faire un
concert rock dans une église 20 ans
évidemment il ya 2 200 je croyais être
200 que j'avais noté le chiffre il ya
plus de 250 églises qui depuis 1950 ont
été désaffectés et qui sont qui sont
désacralisés et qu'on peut utiliser
pourquoi pas les convertir effectivement
mais avec l'accord du public avec
l'accord de nos concitoyens parce que
n'oubliez pas coté des églises de
campagne il ya le cimetière la plupart
du temps et donc quel respect qui est dû
aux morts et elle respect qui est dû à
l'histoire donc encore une fois ça ne
peut pas se faire sans concertation de
mon point de vue mais pourquoi pas c'est
aussi une possibilité
madame longpré voter vous avez évoqué le
problème de l'assistance à la maîtrise
d'ouvragé
le montage financier notamment pour le
patrimoine qui est non protégés
évidemment l'état qui n'a pas les moyens
de vous aider en revanche à des
fonctionnaires qui ont les moyens de
vous demander des comptes en permanence
et je l' ai vécu pour protéger pour
sauver mon monument sans demander jamais
un euro de subvention publique et donc
la seule chose qui me faisait céder
ordonnancement ça vous avez le droit ça
venait pas le droit la couleur comme ci
comme ça très bien vous êtes chez vous
allez faites comme vous voulez le régime
dit à la femme du nord vous êtes quand
même chez vous à bon je peux choisir ma
couleur c'est les factures augmentent
fatalement mais je pense que là il ya
peut-être une jeep à une
déréglementation mais peut-être qu'à une
il ya une sensibilité de l'état par
rapport aux métiers d'art je pense qu'on
pourrait donner la possibilité à tous
ces jeunes dans les chantiers est bien
de faire de participer sans que
forcément il y est alors qu' un
architecte du patrimoine je trouve ça
utile vous avez on a j'étais pas très
pour convenu les les ldd des architectes
et d'aider des bâtiments de france
n'était pas fort non plus parce que
voyez-vous autre face à protéger les
mères beaucoup plus que ça les empêchait
de 2,2 de tourner en rond ça les
protéger il se défaussait vous comprenez
les abf il faut leur redonner leur leur
puissance en tout cas une certaine un
avis plus que consultatif parce que la
bêtise a été de faire quand vous voulez
construire une une chose horrible chez
vous et bien la bf disais oh ben non ça
vous pouvez pas autorisés donc le maire
disait à saône à sont administrés moi je
suis pour mais mon abs ne veux pas ça le
protégeait et garder sa voix maintenant
il dit s'il dit non il perd la voix de
son électeur s'il dit oui il à moosch
son visage voilà donc le choix est fait
et c'est pour ça que je rencontre l'âge
de plus en plus amoché et
c'est un vrai problème plus généralement
du patrimoine donc je pense que pour
tout je vois tous les dossiers qu'on
reçoit avec la fondation du patrimoine
mais qui nous remontent et qui ne
dépendent pas de la drac puisqu'ils ne
sont pas protégés jusqu'à présent il n'y
a que la générosité publique il n'y a
que la fondation du patrimoine puisque
on lance pour vous savez que la
fondation du patrimoine on lance des
quêtes un deck et en ligne des ddd
cagnotte au fond et avec la mission
berne c'est la seule chose qu'on fait
pour le patrimoine non protégé
d'ailleurs dans le choix qui est fait
aujourd'hui on insiste davantage sur les
monuments qui ne sont pas protégés
puisqu'on sait que j'ai obtenus grâce
aux sénateurs d'ailleurs à ce que à
l'euro près soit compensé les les taxes
sur le loto du patrimoine mais ça ne
peut revenir que pour des bâtiments
protégés vous l'avez bien compris parce
qu'on ne peut pas remettre de l'argent
de l'état à des à des bâtiments qui ne
sont pas protégés donc je suis obligé de
faire une péréquation pour faire en
sorte qu' on est davantage des monuments
non protégés pour pour pour que
puisqu'on sait que les protégés
recevront en plus la manne financière du
des crédits qui sont qui sont recrédités
pour pour pour le du loto du patrimoine
dont j'espère que la pérennité est
assurée j'ai tout à l'heure une rendez
vous je je je sais que c'est enregistré
et ses publics je la haute autorité de
régulation des jeux veut renier les
griffes du loto du patrimoine trouve que
c'est scandaleux qu'on réunit les gens
avec 15 euros de tickets alors ça les
choque pas qu'on bingo etc mais ça ça
sans doute la présidente ne va pas
souvent dans les pmu dans les petits
villages mais je vais aller défendre mon
bout de gras et je me bats avec la fonda
avec la fondation du patrimoine et la
française des jeux pour qu'on maintienne
le loto du patrimoine ça a été et voter
choix décidés par le prison république
ont voté par les députés les sénateurs
mais chez eux encore obligé alors qu'on
a on a récolté en cinq ans près de 200
millions d'euros pour le patrimoine
c'est quand même une contribution
importante mais ce qui les gêne c'est
que c'est si vous voulez c'est fléché
voilà il faudrait dire pour toutes les
bonnes causes mais c'est fléché sauf que
cette dame qui visiblement n'a pas
connaissance des dd de l'histoire de
france a obligé de pan de souvenirs que
la loterie lotto a été créée pour sauver
le patrimoine pour le construire pardon
le loto a été créé en italie pour le
patrimoine importés par françois 1er à
la halle à la renaissance pour
construire du patrimoine l'église s'y
est opposée mail où ils 15 a repris
l'idée a construit l'église sainte
geneviève qui deviendra le panthéon puis
ensuite l'école militaire a été
construite avec l'argent des du loto de
la lute la halle aux tories et donc j'ai
argumenté de cela j'ai relu et de cela
pour que ce que le loto avait permis de
faire au xviiie siècle l'auto puisse
permettre de protéger le patrimoine mais
bon il va falloir se battre oui rien
n'est jamais acquis dans ce pays on ne
peut jamais dormir tranquille ensuite
l'entretien du patrimoine je pense
j'irai même plus loin vous avez vous
voyez donné une très bonne idée je pense
d'abord qu'il faut faire un inventaire
complet du patrimoine je pense que c'est
une chose urgente un inventaire complet
du patrimoine paysager une des zones
qu'on ne peut pas toucher on ne mettra
pas d'éoliennes en ne mettra pas de
choses immondes qui vont dénaturer nos
paysages de carte postale
ça c'est une première chose le
patrimoine bâti ensuite le patrimoine
religieux le patrimoine castrale le
patrimoine industriel et ouvrier je
revendique le fait de défendre la
mémoire ouvrière de notre pays je suis
contre le fait qu'on détruise du
patrimoine industriel où nous arrière
grands parents travaillent et ont trimé
je pense que c'est bien de l'est révèle
revalorisé de faire des espaces de
coworking d'en faire des
quand je vois des manufactures qui
ferment je vois par exemple alors à
sarreguemines j'ai vu que l'ancien ils
ont fermé mais on a fait un écomusée les
écomusées c'est intéressant ça permet
justement de redonner une nouvelle
valorisation tôt que je crois qu'il faut
faire un inventaire du patrimoine
immobilier des statuts du patrimoine
vous avez raison madame la sénatrice
vous avez raison il faut défendre tous
ses livres tous ces registres
tout ce bibliothécaire que je vois
dispersé
j'achète voit même dès que je vois
d'aidé qui concerne le monde l'église
abbatiale j'essaye de récupérer mais ça
me fend le coeur de voir que en des
fonds entier de de ce patrimoine écrit
de notre mémoire collective est en train
de partir à l'encan et est brûlé sous le
feu des enchères c'est un drame absolu
ce feu-là personnes non non non non on
parle jamais donc il ya d'abord un pad
un inventaire total puis ensuite je moi
je ferai alors le mot peut-être va
choquer une police du patrimoine on ne
compare est de faire n'importe quoi vous
savez en 1825 puis en 1830 de victor
hugo a écrit son livre sur stop aux
démolisseurs parce qu'on a voulu
détruire une chapelle de l'an et ses
talents qu'est né tout cet élan
justement de victor hugo peau pour
écrire ce pamphlet stop aux démolisseurs
il était choqué c'est qu'au 19e siècle
on continue sur les méthodes d'avant on
fait du passé table rase et ont bâti par
dessus sans se préoccuper de l'histoire
ddd j'allais dire de la sédimentation
des ciels de ce qui s'était passé avant
c'est plus possible aujourd'hui
d'abord parce que il ya une conscience
collective de la prise de conscience de
l'importance du patrimoine d'abord pour
nos racines pour notre histoire pour
notre identité mais aussi simplement
pour notre portefeuille parce que c'est
ce qui permet de faire vivre des
villages dont le seul trésor je le
rappelle c'est le patrimoine religieux
souvent ou le château qui est pas très
loin c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya encore
un commerce est ce qui fait qu on achète
des cartes postales c'est ce qui fait
qu'il ya parfois une auberge où on peut
dormir et on peut se restaurer daube c
c'est un non sens de laisser détruire ce
patrimoine donc je pense qu'il faut que
cette police du patrimoine puisse aussi
édicter des règles on ne peut pas
démolir ce patrimoine on doit au
contraire le protéger et garantir vous
avez raison cette ligne cette fameuse
ligne d'entretien du patrimoine c'est si
vous n'entretenait pas le patrimoine la
facture est exponentielle et à la fin du
compte est bien avec la loi et leur goût
et et et les oies toutes les lois qui
ont été votées depuis pas touche sait
plus comment vous appelez ça ça c'est
une autre et bien en juge que c'est
vétustes et que c'est donc très
dangereux pour pour légende donc il faut
il faut détruire et donc voilà comment
on aboutit à la destruction d'un
patrimoine inestimable
donc pardon de m'enflammer mais je le
dis parce que j'ai participé au jury
d'un magazine qui s'appelle pèlerins
pèlerin magazine donne des prix chaque
année je suis membre de leur jury et ben
voilà il me j'ai eu comme ça j'avais
pris plein la figure d'une cinquantaine
d'églises qui sont toutes en déréliction
qui sont toutes en train de tomber en
ruine mais on doit donner un prix 20
mille euros ici 50000 là mais c'est
c'est pas rien c'est pas rien ça va
aider donc je pense qu'il faut mettre
tous tous se font en commun pour essayer
de sauver si l'église veut d'abord faut
les inventorier faut les répertorier
tout ce patrimoine religieux non
protégés il ya la sauvegarde de l'art
français qui vient aussi au secours à la
fois des retables du patrimoine
religieux immobilier mais vous savez on
a eu un gros problème avec le mobilier
c'est que la ministre la culture les
ministres la culture successivement des
vous touchez à tous vous pouvez sauver
le patrimoine bâti mais vous ne touchez
pas au patrimoine mobilier c'est pas
votre affaire donc j'ai pas pu -
d'occuper j'ai par exemple insisté pour
que la bibliothèque fesch d'ajaccio
puisse être un site emblématique de la
mission bien nommé j'avais pas le roi de
m'occuper des livres donc on a sauvé la
halle enveloppe mais à l'intérieur tout
pourri et là je peux rien faire donc de
vous voyez on est on est dans cette
contradiction est là ou dodo que je
crois que vous avez raison il faut que
vraiment se mobilisent pour les archives
pour les livres que peut-être l'idée de
bruno retailleau et très intéressante
les archives départementales
je vois moi j'ai trouvé énormément de
choses dans les archives départementales
qui ont vocation à protéger ses archives
qui sont la mémoire la mémoire vous
savez si les livres disparaît si les
noms des gens disparaissent pas c'est la
mort assurée nos que c'est ça qu'il faut
protéger parce que on est là pour faire
oeuvre de vie encore une fois c'est pas
les pierres qu'on sauve c'est des âmes
des gens des gens qui ont vécu qui ont
aimé qu'ils ont souffert ensuite les
églises 19e oui souvent ce sont les
églises du 19e siècle qui sont dans en
danger pourquoi parce que on ne
connaissait pas les méthodes on a on a
mélangé les matériaux vous avez très
bien dit monsieur retailleau vous avez
je suis membre de la fondation
saint-louis on essaie de sauver la lah
les travaux sur la chapelle royale saint
louis de dreux et on a ce problème entre
la maçonnerie les la pierre leu leu en
ami on a commencé à mettre de l'acier
qui s'érode évidemment avec les
ruissellements tout ça fait exploser les
pierres c'est beaucoup plus cher
beaucoup plus compliqué de restaurer une
église du 19e siècle là il faut faire
aussi une expertise essayer de les de
les recenser de voir ce qu'on peut faire
et ne pas oublier le patrimoine du xxème
siècle sachant que à partir de 1905 ça
appartient au diocèse et peut être
restaurée aussi alors le jean vient
l'idée le fonds européen j'en ai parlé
beaucoup avec marie à gabriel qui est la
commissaire européen elle a tout à fait
conscience europa nostra essayer de
faire ce qu'ils peuvent mais ils n'ont
pas de moyens et donc ils n'ont aucun
moyen ils ont juste de la communication
alors on vous remet une jolie un joli
prix en vous récompense mais il n'y a
pas d'argent pour aider des églises ou
le patrimoine religieux je pense qu'il
ya énormément de bonne volonté il a
énormément de gens qui veulent aider je
crois qu'il faut les mettre ensemble il
faut créer vraiment un fond vous avez
raison un fonds commun un fonds citoyens
sont alors peut-être on peut assigner
cette émission à la fondation du
patrimoine qui fait ça très bien où l
observatoire l'observatoire du
patrimoine religieux il faut peut-être
essayer de travailler ensemble pour
trouver des solutions pour que tout
c'est une petite rivière et bien
confluent et aillent ensemble aider le
patrimoine religieux mais encore une
fois il ya aussi les centres bourgs faux
pas dans l'action que l'état mène dans
l'est dans les bourgs faut jamais
oublier les églises parce que les
églises ou les synagogues
j'étais très touché de ce que racontait
madame d'ex clair à la fois son église
qui a lui demande 900000 euros la petite
synagogue
alsacienne qu'elle rachète mais ils ont
pas les moyens
vous savez on est j'ai l'impression
d'être dans un bateau qui prend l'eau et
d'écoper avec une cuillère à soupe et et
c'est terrible parce que d'un côté j'ai
l'église affectataire qui m'appelle
venez nous aider un père une une soeur
une mère eux supérieurs qui m'appellent
pour son couvent ensuite j'ai le grand
rabbin haïm korsia team appelle ma
synagogue de bayonne quand est-ce que tu
t'en occupes enfin vous voyez j'ai
l'impression d'être d'être d'être devenu
l'interlocuteur pardon de le dire mais
vous savez quand j'ai commencé ma
mission il ya eu un article très méchant
de monsieur je veux j'oublie son nom de
dans le monde qui disait ah bah il se
substituait la force publique c'est pas
ma vocation je viens là bénévolement
parce que contrairement à eux tous je ne
suis pas payé je fais ça avec mon argent
et mes moyens et mon temps et c'est une
mission bénévole que le président de la
république m'a confiées et on vient me
dire vous le substitut à la force mis
knock je viens en soutien mais mais bon
sens pour comment vous expliquez que
toutes les demandes viennent vers moi
ouvert la fondation du patrimoine
maintenant qu'il a choisi ouvrière de ma
mission ce n'est pas normal c'est qu'il
ya une déficience de l'état est
d'ailleurs le rapport delà de la cour
des comptes le montre bien il ya un
problème justement voulait peut-être lui
je viens d'en lire les grandes lignes
c'est quand même c'est comme un problème
la politique de l'état en soussou sur le
patrimoine pose quand même un certain
nombre de questions donc le patrimoine
religieux voilà un pôle j'espère avoir
répondu en partie à vos questions j'y
suis pas content quand l'église est
d'accord pour désacraliser par contre
j'ai eu une petite pique et je le dis
parce que je le vois dans certaines
églises le clergé n'est pas toujours
notre notre notre allié
le il ya beaucoup d'églises ou parfois
des install des filons mais des
projecteurs on met des
les l'église est affectataire mais elle
doit respecter les règles du patrimoine
et je pense que c'est bien de temps en
temps de le rappeler aussi donc moi je
veux bien aller secourir le
secourir le patrimoine religieux mais il
faut aussi que ceux qui en ont la la
gestion au quotidien qui sont
affectataire de ce patrimoine le
défendent aussi
merci pour votre enthousiasme et une
fille pour la passion que vous avez
communiqué vous avez vu que c'est pas
sûr et entièrement partagée par
l'ensemble des membres de notre
commission à travers les interventions
des uns et des autres la préoccupation
qui est la banque ne partageons
complètement c'est une préoccupation
dont on doit collectivement
faire se faire l'écho et le porte parole
parce qu'on voit l'immensité votre image
à la fin de votre propos sur
l'impression que vous avez d'écoper avec
une cuillère c'est un peu le sentiment
que nous et que nous avons tout ce qui
justifie pleinement la mobilisation de
chacun sur ce sujet central de la
protection du patrimoine en tout cas
nous avons toujours plaisir à vous
entendre et surtout à travailler avec
vous et nous continuerons de me faire
bien entendu on a noté votre rendez-vous
cet après-midi gestionnaire qui se ça
sera ça se passera bien
la française des jeux m'a garanti qu on
aurait au moins entre 25 et 30 millions
mais vous savez c'est 25 et 30 millions
me serve de levier à partir du moment où
l'autre
parent dont les départements les régions
les fonds européens le dr et ses îles
mèdes elle et les p ô terre aussi les
parcs lippi nous aide parce que c'est un
gars je vois qu'on a comme eux je les
seuls fierté que je peux avoir vous
savez c'est la grâce et ses cénac parce
que c'est donc on n'était pas nombreux
au début et donc franchement d'avoir
réussi il ya souillac maintenant on va
ça c'est les grands monuments mais et là
où je rebondis aussi part à tanger jour
j'ai l'esprit d'escalier mais catherine
morency par led et en europe peut-être
on devrait travailler sur les chemins
les chemins de compostelle les chemins
les les chemins clunisiens aussi il y à
là qu'ils quittent j'allais dire qu'ils
sont européens sont des chemins
européens essaient de l'aide européenne
petit peu
apportez abondé pour nos églises on a
merci en tout cas de m'avoir écouté je
sais que j'ai toujours une écoute
attentive au sénat c'est pour ça que
j'ai toujours plaisir à revenir vous
voir et en tout cas pardon d'être d'être
un passionné engagé mais je fais ça tout
mon coeur est et je vais continuer
jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive
[Musique]